news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
donald trump held another rally
yesterday this time it was in moon
township pennsylvania which is where i
guess the pittsburgh airport is
trump arriving in every state and
basically telling them all the same
thing now
your state had its best year ever last
year
then the china virus came in as he calls
it but next year is going to be the best
again it's going to be the best
year ever next year trump seemed sort of
particularly wound up yesterday maybe he
was reacting to
early news that the vaccine emergency
use authorization he had been hoping for
for october is not going to happen as we
discussed earlier in the program
could have been anything you never know
could have seen something on the plane
on the way in that
enraged him let's look at some
outrageous moments i know that lots of
these rallies start to blend together
but
we are under six weeks from the election
and people are voting now
early voting absentee voting i don't
want any of this behavior to be
normalized
so we're going to keep talking about it
maybe the strangest moment of the entire
event was donald trump lamenting
that he doesn't have any friends anymore
check this out the crowd
sort of doesn't know what to make of it
i could call up every guy
they call me up and they say sir how are
you sir
mr president sir i have frenzy i don't
have too many friends up because
i used to be comfortable you have to be
comfortable with people right
and i have friends i have one friend
richard i talk about them all the time
but they're
multiply this times 100 people and
richard used to call me up five six
years ago hey let's have dinner
all right where do you want to go i
don't know go to some crazy restaurant
today the restaurants are all closed in
new york they don't want to open them
they want to make them do badly until
november don't worry they're opening on
november 4th
but it's true so it's richard on the
phone richard my friend for many many
years
and i said hey rich mr president sir how
are you i said well
he's been calling me donny and don and
dj
and all richard are you okay everything
good
uh yes sir mr president sir you're doing
a great job and
i'd like to thank you good richard
richard listen up please you don't have
to call me mr president
i said so just call me donald it's okay
thank you donald i really appreciate it
and you hear the guy he can't breathe
you know he's having a hard time
breathing
he's very nervous and then at the end of
the phone he goes mr president again
thank you so much for the job you're
doing hangs up i said how can you be
friends with you know
it just doesn't work it's like i've lost
a lot of people this way
there is a lot going on there
psychologically that would be
great fodder for a few years of
psychotherapy for donald trump really a
ton of it
but as a story to tell at a rally it is
bizarre
and odd and then this was maybe my
favorite
moment of the entire rally trump did the
sir routine
about melania his wife so the sir
routine is
when trump tells a story of someone
talking to him he'll he'll say
and they came to me and they said sir
we can't do it or whatever right this
time
he tells a story in which melania
refers to him as sir outrageously
bizarre
happening that thing would turn around
like a pretzel
and i said oh it does move but they
never want to show
the crowds they never last night now i
went home and i tell you this i go home
all the time first lady
how'd you like the crowd sir i didn't
see it
i didn't see it melania said to trump
sir i didn't see the crowd
how strange is that is this confirmation
that trump's sir stories or lies
or is this an admission from trump that
his wife refers to him as sir
either way it's not exactly stable
genius
then trump went back to something he's
been talking about more and more lately
which is space exploration nasa nars
as he referred to it over the weekend
mars of course as you and i would know
it
and trump i guess because he's just
constantly thinking about golf
talked about nasa's great uh
fairways rather than runways take a look
on the moon in the united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut
on mars you know nasa was an absolute
disaster grass was growing through the
fair
the the fairways too they had fairways
that's about all they used with a
fairway
and now we have something right through
the the runways
totally just utterly unintelligible
donald trump i don't know if people have
noticed this but we saw it there
trump does this unintentionally
hilarious thing
where most people when they read a
speech off of a prompter
the the idea is these are my words that
i'm reading this is my
speech trump reads the prompter
almost like he's reading a news article
and reacts to what's on the prompter
like it's news
and sometimes he actually seems sort of
like surprised by what's on the prompt
or it's bizarre
then trump went into these uh
our our friend aaron rupar on twitter
called it gore
porn gore porn about ms-13
using knives it this it just just makes
almost no sense at all
if you don't mind democrats we'll bring
them the hell out of our country we'll
get them out of here
some of them are so violent we have to
keep them we don't want to house them
for 50 years
but if we let them go they come back in
as much as we watch you know look if
they come back in we don't want it we
don't want them so we keep them here we
have no choice if the
left gains power they will abolish
republicans will always they cannot
abolish republicans will always stand
with
these incredible heroes of ice and
border patrol
you have to see these ice people they go
into a den
of ms-13 they call them a den a nest
where you have these
guys that are vicious vicious gang
members
and they go in there they just start
swinging it's the craziest thing they
love it
now who wants that job do you want that
job even look he's a tough guy
setting it you too you're tough guys you
don't want any part of it they're just
incredible
and they love our country they love our
country and then people say oh they're
too rough
they're so rough you have no idea how
bad some of these gangs are what they do
they use knives because it's more
painful
they cut people up again the crowd is a
mix of people
some who will just clap at anything
trump there was a particular woman
behind trump
no matter what he said she would start
pumping her fists and and you know
cheering
anything he said but then there's
another half of the crowd that has
no idea what trump is talking about they
go almost silent during these rallies
because it's all crazy trump then went
into the portion of the speech which
he's been doing lately
where he glorifies violence against
journalists
here he's talking about how funny it is
that a guy who was a reporter
was manhandled by law enforcement
grabbed them
they grabbed them they were grabbing
them left and right
sometimes they grab they grab one guy
i'm a reporter i'm a reporter
get out of here they threw him aside
like he was a little bag of popcorn
but no but i mean honestly when you
watch the crap that we've all had to
take so long
when you see that it's actually you
don't want to do that but when you see
it it's actually a beautiful sight
it's a beautiful sight trump says
reporters tossed around
by law enforcement you love to see it
says trump and again the crowd
some are cheering mindlessly but others
are sort of wondering like wait a second
we we toss around reporters now that
should i really be cheering for this
like there actually are some people in
the crowd who
you can see are a little tentative about
what trump is is talking about and then
continuing with the glorification of
violence against reporters
trump keeps mocking msnbc reporter ali
velshi
for getting hit with a rubber bullet or
tear gas in minneapolis
he refers to him as the cnn guy he's not
a cnn guy he's msnbc take a listen
go in we have the national guard and
remember that beautiful site
the street was a mess that idiot
reporter from cnn got hit on the knee
with a canister of tear gas right
and he went down i've been hit i've been
hit
he been hit the one with the shaved hair
shaved the hair maybe i'll do that one
day i'll give it up
so again he keeps telling the same story
the cnn guy the bald cnn guy he's
talking about msnbc's ali velshi
but we're laughing at media getting hit
that that does not seem american to me
it seems like the exact opposite
of everything i thought this country
was supposed to stand for and then trump
plays up
the joe biden dementia stuff and the joe
biden is on drug stuff
that loves off this guy doesn't have a
clue he doesn't know where the hell he
is
and they'll give him a shot of something
i don't know he's going to get something
he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test we want a drug test
we'll both take it
we're both yet trump just continues to
act like
you know biden before the bernie debate
was like sami sosa juicing
to get more home runs or something like
that very very strange and of course
not totally unreasonable to see this as
projection
maybe it's trump who's using uppers
to increase his performance and then the
last one that's just hilarious
um trump asks the crowd what gas costs
these days
and someone yells out that it costs 15
dollars
and trump seems to believe it energy
almost seven
thousand dollars but we have to include
energy i mean how much are you paying
for your gasoline
you never saw two dollar gasoline you're
less right it's less
they go up it's less now it's uh it's
a big difference what is it nowadays
come on tell me i haven't got any guests
i haven't stopped recently at a gas
station i'm
15. okay because for a while it was uh
way under two imagine being so out of
touch
that you think gas might cost 15
per gallon like that would be weird for
the average american
maybe if you live in a city you don't
drive
you don't even go by a gas station or
when you do you don't look like
maybe somebody might not know is where
exactly is gas
trump is the president and he's talking
about gas prices and
someone yells out 15 and trump thinks
gas might be 15
a gallon i've had an electric car for a
while
i've not been to gas stations for a
while but i can be reasonably certain
that gas is like between 1.80 and 370 a
gallon right if somebody says gas is 15
a gallon it doesn't pass the sniff test
trump is the president and he says oh
it's at 15.
uh no rally on today's schedule for
donald trump
as of right now he is scheduled to do a
press
conference um reminder september 29th
just six days away the first debate
between joe biden and donald trump i
will be streaming it live
starting at 8 30 p.m in the east 5
30 p.m in the west on youtube twitch and
facebook
and i do hope that you will join me